so und jetzt wollen wir nach österreich
schauen dort steht nämlich bereits fest
dass die impfpflicht kommen wird und wie
man natürlich wissen wir wollen die
österreicher das eigentlich durchziehen
zugeschaltet ist rainer nowak er ist
chefredakteur von die presse schön dass
sie da sind nowak
jetzt war man natürlich wissen wie genau
soll das denn in österreich umgesetzt
werden die impfpflicht
also ist kam auch in österreich sehr
ruckartig und quasi über nacht bei einer
nächtlichen sitzung der landes- der
ministerpräsident in österreichs und der
bundesregierung wurde nicht lange
diskutiert nicht lange besprochen
sondern mehr oder weniger innerhalb
kurzer zeit angekündigt dass wir ab
februar eine impfpflicht haben werden
dass ich erstaunlich finden wie schnell
und die kurzfristig sowas sonst seien
wichtiger als wichtiges gesetz oder
wichtiger eigentlich passieren wird wir
werden innerhalb von glaube ich ein aber
auch ein gesetzestext einen
gesetzesentwurf vorliegen habe am 6
dezember also bisher schon wissen wir
haben uns einmal nicht wurf besorgt
dieses entwurf ist es noch ein sehr
vages papier und dass die details
beinhaltet unter anderem dass es relativ
hohe geldstrafen geben sie hoch wie hoch
3600 euro beim beim erstmals verweigern
bei mehrmaligen verweigern kann das bis
zu 7200 euro betragen ob das dann so
umgesetzt wird wage ich jetzt mal zu
bezweifeln
das ganze so aufgesetzt dass man von der
gesundheitskasse beziehungsweise von den
behörden einen impftermin vorgeschlagen
bekommt wenn man noch nicht geimpft ist
aber das können die behörden und kommt
dem stand und ich habe nach dem zweiten
dritten mal aber man ist der jüngste und
fern bleibt bekommt man eine strafe ob
das tatsächlich dann alle menschen der
zur prüfung bringen wird wage ich zu
bezweifeln bestimmt nicht gewissen
effekt hat es sicher österreich ist bei
uns ähnlich wie deutschland sich gegen
deutschland schlecht wir haben da wir
sind noch nicht mehr ganz bei 70 prozent
im winter besser ein tick besser sind
wir in deutschland auch ein tief bei
services lippstadt ausweise sie sind
immer schneller mit dem chor ohne regeln
und wir sind tick besser beim impfen
aber haben sie überhaupt die daten da
das haben wir in deutschland gar nicht
wir wissen gar nicht wie der im staat
uns von allen deutschen ist also
offenbar weiß die österreichische
gesundheitsbehörde kennt den impfstatus
von alves ist das so
das sollte so seien vermutlich sogar
menschen die bereits geimpft sind noch
nicht gemeldet sind aber prinzipiell hat
die behörde hat die behörde dieses
dieses dieses diese diese daten und kann
das schicken also wir reden hier von
adressen wir reden von den von den
impfungen herr nowak die impfpflicht sei
ja nun auch für kinder gelten wir
konnten das beim volk an
das wird überhaupt sehr heftig
diskutiert weil wir haben ja auch in
österreich eine partei mit der
freiheitlichen partei die von anfang an
eine massive haben die im kampf waren
gefahren ist also freiheitliche partei
rechtspopulistische ähnlich wie die afg
aber professioneller und auch größer man
hat das ganz klar ist dem er für sich
entdeckt und mache die unglaubliche
stimmung und das kinder thema ist
natürlich ein besonders sensibles laut
dem ersten entwurf ob das dann wirklich
so kommen wird in textentwurf also laut
diesem papier denn das uns zur verfügung
gestellt steht steht drin dass kinder
bis zwölf also jugendliche gegen stern
bis 12 sollen keine kinder geimpft und
tester war bei ihnen ja schon gesehen
vor allen dingen in wien am wochenende
immer heftige proteste teilweise auch
ausschreitungen wie es im moment ihr
eindruck wie gehen die österreicher
damit um die sich bis heute nicht helfen
lassen also werden die am ende durch die
impfpflicht an die impfrate gebracht
oder sagen wie das interessiert mich
jemand und ich werde mich trotzdem nicht
selten lassen und bestimmte anteile
haben wird sich das definitiv verweigert
da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher einen
anderen teil wird man vielleicht zu den
impfungen bekommen interessant ist dass
diese gruppe in österreich sehr
inhomogen ist das ist von von von grün
grün besorgten esoterisch wer einfluss
menschen die das salär ist sagen wir
sehr sehr sehr passt ja natur ecke
kommen bis hin zu eher am rechtsextremen
ist das eine ganz breite sammelbewegung
eines der größten probleme in österreich
ist derzeit das gilt auch für
deutschland nämlich an das wäre eine
sehr hohe anzahl von ungeimpften
schwangeren personen haben frauen haben
haben und das sind mittlerweile in der
gynäkologischen station in college
station intensivstation die betten voll
das ist ein riesenproblem aber man wenn
man auf die demonstrationen geht also es
sind jetzt zwar ausschreitungen gewesen
aber ist jetzt nicht das
thema sind auch ganz normale junge junge
frauen die der demonstrieren gehen also
die haben jetzt eine situation weil wir
eine sehr starke politisch aufgeheizte
situation unabhängig von corona hatten
aber mit dem rücktritt von abt und
kaarster sebastian kurz und dann im
neuen bundeskanzler und das hat doch
dazu geführt dass wir der einzige
streitereien in den vergangenen monaten
erlebt haben dass ich krank werde das
thema co wicona sowie die deutschen im
wahlkampf gekümmert hat das würde
jährlich elegant ausgeblendet und alle
haben gehofft dass geht von alleine weg
und siehe da jetzt kommt es wieder
zurück und die impfkampagne die vor dem
sommer recht stark war und sehr große
fahrt aufgenommen hat ist über den
sommer dann völlig eingeschlafen und
irgendwie jetzt keiner mehr wirklich
darum gekümmert aber ich glaube da gibt
es leider auch eine breite ist
österreich und deutschland absolute gibt
es ja nur war dankeschön für diesen
einblicke in österreich danke
verdienen jetzt auch wieder nach
deutschland im pflicht wieder härtere
kroner maßnahmen weil eben die lage in
den krankenhäusern immer schwieriger
wird allerdings endlich gibt es auch mal
wieder einen echten hoffnungsschimmer in
unserem colorada
ganz genau so ist es und wir wollen mit
dem wichtigsten wert wieder anfangen
nämlich der hospitalisierung since it
ends also diesem rechnerischen wert der
beschreibt wie voll ist es aktuell in
den krankenhäusern wie bedrohlich die
lage auf den intensivstationen dass die
deutschlandkarte der hospitalisierung
since i denn sie müssen sich einmal drei
werte märkten 3 ist grün 6 ist orange
und ab 9 wird roth ab 9 droht dann in
diesen bundesländern tatsächlich der
locker und bis dahin ist okay grün ist
im moment niedersachsen da ist es
relativ entspannt vor allen dingen weil
es hier oben an der nordseeküste noch
alles relativ easy ist in den
krankenhäusern niedersachsen top-wert
hier im moment deutlich unter 3 und ganz
genau so eben aktuell in hamburg gleich
nebenan aber in bremen schon ein
bisschen enger über sechs der wert und
sie sehen dann wo es rot und orange ist
neuerdings ist mecklenburg vorpommern
hier ein bisschen weiter oben dabei also
diesen knapp unter dieser schwelle da
drohen also regional noch härtere
maßnahmen in sachsen anhalt und
thüringen das sind eben weitere
spitzenreiter während bayern sich hier
aktuell so ein bisschen stabilisiert
macht da hat man ja patienten nach
nordrhein-westfalen geflogen wo die lage
ein bisschen entspannter noch ist
patienten nach hamburg geflogen und
jetzt aktuell stabilisiert sich das da
unten ein bisschen während es vor allen
dingen eben in thüringen spitze wer hier
mit
21,5 bei der hospitalisierung incidents
weiterhin knallrotes aber es gibt eben
diesen hoffnungsschimmer denn viele
gerade angesprochen hat wir schauen mal
auf die neuansteckungen in deutschland
also wie viel gibt es da aktuell wir
kennen das aus den letzten tagen dass
diese balken immer weiter nach oben
ausschlagen aber genau das passiert
jetzt plötzlich seit einigen tagen eben
nicht mehr das hier das ist immer noch
eine dramatische corinna lage in
deutschland aber wir sehen jetzt heute
diesen wert 67.000
186 wir kommen ein bisschen weiter
runter zumindest stabilisieren sich die
zahlen die inzidenz die höhe der wert
der neuansteckungen der stabilisiert
sich seit einigen tagen in deutschland
vor allem auch in süddeutschland das ist
ein trend den wir in bayern sehen seit
dem wochenende und das könnte doch ein
hoffnungsschimmer sein zumindest sind
das ganz wichtige zahlen für morgen für
den corona gipfel nicht immer alles
schlimmer nicht immer noch voller auf
den intensivstationen seit einigen tagen
stabilisieren sich diese zahlen
stagnieren sie und wir müssen jetzt
einmal dahinter schauen hinter genau
diese stagnation bei den corinna zahlen
ist das ein hoffnungsschimmer könnte das
möglicherweise im beginnenden corona
winter eine echte trendwende sein
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
virologen klaus stöhr wie
stöhr ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet live
erstellt schön dass sie zeit für uns
haben wie schätzen sie jetzt die korona
lage ein vor allem diese stagnierenden
zahlen können wir jetzt von einer
trendwende sprechen oder ist das nur ein
statistischer ausreißer
ja ich würde schon sehr gern mehr
hoffnung streuen allerdings nehmen wir
gegenwärtig das was bei drei bis vier
wochen schon klar war in den hotspot
trennt sich die infektion langsam tot
das heißt nicht dass jetzt gleich
abwehrt schwung kommt sondern dass sich
die situation auf hoher ebene ein kegeln
wird weil einfach nicht mehr genügend
empfängliche personen da sind ja aber es
gibt immer wieder eine
kombinationslösung also in den hotspots
sehen da eine leichte entspannung aber
in den anderen regionen wird das noch
ein weilchen dauern bevor dann die dass
das heißt aber noch nicht dass der
winter vorbei ist das heißt noch nicht
dass die ohren die denzel sind das heißt
noch nicht dass der das boostern und die
im lückenschließung und kontakt
beschränkungen vollständig wegfallen
können aber wir sehen tatsächlich das
exponentielle wagt nun nicht unendlich
hoch gehen so wie man das ja auch in den
vergangenen wellen schon gesehen hat
aber das ist ja in wahrheit schon mal
eine ganz gute nachricht auch wenn sie
gerne noch ein bisschen mehr hoffnung
machen würden herr stöhr aber sieht man
da in diesen zahlen die wir jetzt gerade
gezeigt haben in diesen werten schon so
einen kleinen booster effekt wir stehen
jetzt mittlerweile bei ungefähr elf
prozent der deutschen die schon ihre
dritte impfung bekommen haben also ist
dieser effekt da jetzt schon erkennbar
ich glaube nicht dass die informieren
neben großen anteil hat an dem heute
sehen das ist der natürliche weil
einfach in einer gewissen gruppe von
menschen eine gewisse anpassung von
kontakten möglich sind und nach zwei
drei vier wochen ist das ausgereift aber
natürlich schauen sich an wir haben die
jetzt eine mobilität und eine
kontaktmöglichkeit wie fast in 2009/10
gleichzeitig natürlich eine sehr hohe
decke im vergleich mit 2020 und daraus
ergibt nicht dann diese balance zwischen
energy spielen berichteten fällen
vergleichsweise
wenig tun ist schon sehr viel im detail
jona das künftig im letzten winter zu
den spitzenzeiten waren das ja was 1000
gewesen also hier großer unterschied
also wir sehen schon dass diese wachstum
die unendliche werden wird
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten wochen
noch der viele fälle auch auf den
intensivstationen erkennen können aber
was sie aussehen und ihrer grafik kann
doch nicht so gut raus das ist mehr
große regionale unterschiede gibt
nämlich viele infektionen viele
hospitalisierung eine menge person nach
großen anteil auf den intensivstationen
in bayern in sachsen in thüringen aber
gleichzeitig relativ entspannter im
vergleich entspannte situation im
nordwesten und das nicht und so muss man
natürlich auch die bekämpfung dann
kanalisieren es kann nicht sein dass man
mit mehr dann über deutschland wieder
rüber fährt und sie gedacht die
restaurants schließt in einem
regierungsbezirk weil 1000 kilometer
entfernung die intensivstation verlaufen
ich hoffe wirklich dass jetzt dass man
jetzt regional und auf die situation
angepasst reagiert wird das sind auch
die mensch wieder mit dann sehen sie
nämlich okay wir haben da wohl im staate
wir passen uns an wir haben die kontakte
reduzieren und dann funktioniert das
auch in den anderen regionen wo die
decke dünn ist da sieht man natürlich
auch das dann wirklich mehr insekten und
spinnen und die leute schwerer erkranken
und mehr auf die tiefgründigen klare
ansage von klaus stört nicht mit dem
rasenmäher über deutschland hinweg
sondern regionale maßnahmen gezielt
setzen um das virus einzudämmen
dankeschön fürs interview